bitcoin
come on down what's going on bitcoin all
right um
i'm surprised you didn't say anything
about what i look like today i wasn't
going to say you look like a lumberjack
but you look like a lumberjack we got
sherwin-williams lumberjack what is this
halloween on this show go ahead chopping
wood um okay
or playing baseball
okay bitcoin
fell below 26 000 for the first time in
16 months amid a broader sell-off in
cryptocurrencies that erase more than
200
billion dollars from the entire market
in a single day what do you know
look out below
[Applause]
what is this price has fallen guess what
a couple of things there's three things
three things i want to talk about first
fundamentals
strong as hell hash rate looks great
number of uh nodes in the lightning
network looks great active users uh
transaction volumes all look healthy and
end with unchained measures you can see
who's buying who's selling you know
who's buying
the plebs the average retail person they
just accumulate and they're just
stacking sats if you look at bitcoin on
chain wallet addresses with at least
.01 bitcoin about 285 dollars continues
to hit all-time high after all-time high
after all-time high the small guy the
retail guys they're buying they're
stacking sats now of course institutions
point number two they had a lot of
bitcoin they're fearful bitcoin is their
risk asset as they look in the market
like oh everything is falling apart the
world is ending they're selling they're
dumping they're dumping they're dumping
they're dumping so naturally bitcoin's
been falling third point
bitcoin's realized cap think of this as
the cost basis for all of the bitcoin on
the market cost basis meaning that the
last time that bitcoin traded hands
let's say i had bitcoin i got it at a
dollar and i waited till ten thousand
dollars and then i sold it to polina
realize cap goes and says that bitcoin
last traded at ten thousand dollars so
that adds ten thousand dollars to the
realized capitalization and it
calculates for every single bitcoin on
chain what was the price that last
traded hands that is the cost basis of
bitcoin for bitcoin holders sitting
right around 24 000 or so in the past
few times it has dropped below that
barely but usually around the realized
price point tends to be a signal that
hey we're getting kind of close to the
bottom i ain't calling the bottom i'm
never calling a bottle i'm done with
predictions but good
i think that it is important for you to
pay attention to the on-chain metrics
there's two ways to look at the bitcoin
market today you could be scared you
could be fearful you could sit there and
say the world's ending or you could sit
down
this morning i sat down for coffee with
somebody looked around
and i said
there's opportunity everywhere now you
just got to figure out what you're going
to do next i don't know i'm kind of over
the 20s let's get to the 30s
what about the 50s or 100s or 500s or
the millions what do you mean
what are you talking about okay let's go
no no no i meant like the year not the
oh i thought i'd say 20 thousands 30
thousands 50 thousands hundred thousands
i'm over the 2020s oh 2020 since 2022 go
ahead yeah i'm done with student loans
student loan debt hits another record
high what's it at now 1.6 trillion 1.59
trillion yes good game wow
okay so the debt category accounts for
just 10 of total household debt which is
nearing a whopping 16 trillion the
second this is the second largest
category of consumer debt behind home
mortgages
wow crisis wow what do you think they
should do god do you think that they
should go ahead and uh uh absolve all
the debt
well should i cancel it if you're gonna
do that can you absolve my whole
mortgage
you got home mortgages you got credit
cards you got uh student loans you got
all kinds of nonsense i mean
it's absurd
well 1.59 trillion dollars i don't know
student loans and my guess is that
majority of it literally the people who
got the job are going to take 20 30 40
years so there's all kinds of issues
here i do not think that they should
absolve it what i think that they should
do is first most importantly is knock
off the incentives
so that more people don't keep going in
debt i agree stop stop the problem from
exasperating from accelerating yeah
they're trying to then go back and fix
the pass problem i agree
but that's not what they're doing it's
like a waterfall and you can't just
never mind you gotta move
you gotta move to the you gotta move
upstream
there's literally it's just
they're going down to the end like hey
maybe we can get a pail and we can get
the water out of the river let's get the
water out of the river no what do you do
go build a dam to hold the water back
and then deal with what's downstream of
the damn that's exactly what i was
trying to say but i was too tired to
make the analogy that's why that's why
we're a good team
that actually sounded like that sounds
like way uh okay that sounded way worse
than just because i'm a lumberjack
doesn't mean you can man him you had
broad shoulders from all of that axing
that you were all right go ahead okay
this is sad news i i think we only have
bad news but then it gets better
more than 107
000 americans died of drug overdoses
last year setting another tragic record
in the nation's escalating overdose
epidemic and a lot of this wow
so that means that there was an overdose
every five minutes it marked a 15
increase from the previous record and i
i really do think like
with the pandemic with all the stuff
that's going on in the world people are
forgetting like there is an opioid
crisis in this
opioid crisis there's only one piece of
it in other drugs but i personally have
known a few people in the last
two or three years who have died of
overdoses the part that
contributes to this is one all the
opioid stuff there's a group of people i
will not say their name but they were
literally making billions of dollars off
stuffing opioids down the throats of
america why wouldn't you say their name
because i don't need to be getting into
all that business sacklers and then uh
on top of that there is uh a fentanyl
crisis with china
why are we cool with china they are
flushing america with fentanyl
knock it off address the problem
acknowledge the problem and address the
problem i am not an expert i don't know
what the solution is but what i do know
is it doesn't seem like anyone is paying
attention or addressing it so we need
leadership whether it's at the state at
the federal level to go and address that
issue
third
third
is that the pandemic actually created a
situation where they forced people into
their homes but if you remember liquor
stores stayed open
and it likely led to all kinds of mental
health issues depression uh uh what do
they call it uh when you are by yourself
isolation isolation etc and so that i'm
not saying that is the sole cause but i
am saying that that doesn't help a
situation where if you were somebody who
was kind of teetering on the edge you
needed some help
or financial troubles your
wife left you your husband left you your
kid told them told you that they don't
like you okay i mean that kids do that
whatever would you cry if sophia ever
said that to you sophie had never said
that to me
um well so you're right so it's she's
smarter
fentanyl and other synthetic opioids
surpassed 71 000 up 23 from the year
before there was also a 23 increase in
deaths involving cocaine and a 34
increase in deaths involving meth and
other stimulants a lot of the cocaine
deaths and maybe meth too i'm not as
familiar uh with uh the lacing of
fentanyl but i've read multiple articles
about how uh people go like i think
there was a baseball player a couple of
months ago um who was on maybe spring
break if i remember and uh they went
they bought cocaine
and then it was laced with fentanyl so
these are people who aren't even
necessarily thinking that they are
buying fentanyl i don't know but they
end up having it in the drugs that they
go to use and therefore it ended up
leading to an overdose it just makes me
really sad bad situation and it makes me
upset at our government that they're
doing nothing to help okay can i can i
say something else why hey kids don't do
drugs
like
i feel like that message kind of got you
know like dare right remember that i
know the dare program do they have that
in school still i don't know i do
remember that though i was like new to
the united states i was like what the
hell is dare
yeah anyway by the way i don't think
plants like uh marijuana should be
lumped into this guy we don't need to
get into okay so google announced
several new gadgets uh including its
long-awaited pixel watch so google's
coming out with a smartwatch
have they tried this before i ain't
buying it um
so the pixel watch you do you want me to
tell you what it does
it's google i'm
apple watches
and sports a refined and sleek look that
could appeal to customers who use
android instead of iphone i say cater to
the android people yeah android people
need that listen android people i love
you guys that's fine you just have
second rate devices but that's fine uh
i'm joking not really but i am joking
not really uh so if you think about
android by the way one of the most
important stats i think android
penetration
globally is almost 90 yeah of course
right so iphone users very
western-centric uh and i do think you
get locked into an ecosystem right like
you guess what i got an iphone for the
first time i don't know years ago and i
had just an iphone and then i was like
damn i want my phone and my computer so
i need to get a laptop right well guess
what now i got a keyboard now i got a
mouse right then i got a smart watch
like you just get locked into the
ecosystem google by the way the smart
move which i think they're trying to do
here is gonna do the same thing they're
gonna try to lock you into the android
ecosystem uh and so it makes sense for
them to do it but i'm just not buying it
okay
like you gotta you gotta make a you
gotta make a choice there is
no one foot in one foot out i'm just
really like do you know what i wish
happened i wish that apple created a
band instead of a watch because i want
the functionality of the apple watch
stats but i want to wear a nice watch i
don't want this do you know how ugly
this is ugly speak for yourself ugly
anyway it should look sleek to me
that's because you'll be going to mars
like what time is it
that's because you're you and i'm me
okay well i wouldn't expect a lumberjack
to like a watch like that go ahead
i only wear rolex eye
rolexes
i don't know my mom's maddie yes sounds
like you really got a lot of rolexes if
you can't even pronounce it
rolex i with an x at the end or is it
just rolex plural like deer
no it's a fox like you got some roll-ups
you got a roll
but my mom's mad at me because
apparently she gifted me a rolex back in
the day and i don't know where it is oh
gosh
and apparently yeah it was hers and then
not mine and then i lost it i don't want
to talk about it why are you making me
talk about it okay so
don't give me gifts
especially nice ones okay a passenger
with no flying experience i'm so
confused
a passenger with no flying experience
landed a plane in florida after the
pilot passed out
isn't that incredible
the human brain okay no no no no no no
no i can't i can't let this narrative
take hold let me tell you
did they actually land it or were they
sitting there while the plane landed
itself which most planes this day can do
no in their truck so so the pilot passes
out and then unfortunately passenger but
he's fine now the passenger darren
calls air traffic control and says
there's a serious situation like help me
out i've got a serious situation here my
pilot has gone incoherent good for you
darren for using the word incoherent in
such a serious situation i don't know
that word i have no idea how to fly the
airplane and then
and then the air traffic controller who
also teaches new pilots helped to guide
the man down to palm beach international
airport that's incredible what a
heartwarming story so the plane probably
landed itself no by the way still hero
hero
hero
okay
but
i don't think somebody's just sitting
down without all of the instrumentation
that's going on today and the automation
and doing that in a big plane oh this oh
hold on it's accessible
i thought this was like a 747 is that a
passenger oh my god okay by the way but
still impressed i'm still impressed
color me surprised but still impressed
colorless
you talking about a little like a little
cessna
yeah
like it's like a that looks like a
puddle jumper yeah and do you know how
terrifying those are
are they yes and so
so the the i have a brother who could
fly one of those i know but do you know
how long it took him to be able to fly
no
literally they literally were like just
go up there no
with the instructor person so so the air
traffic controllers i'm impressed bubble
i'm just giving her i knew the plane was
flying like any other plane i just knew
i had to keep him calm point him to the
runway and tell him how to reduce the
power so he could descend to land
wow
damn this guy should get an award i i
think so yeah like like we should just
in society we should just have a award
like a dope [ __ ] award if you do dope
[ __ ] in the world you're a good person
you should get the award so after the
plane landed the air traffic guys
somebody said did you did you say the
passengers landed the airplane and the
pilot responded with oh my god grave
dram that's pretty good i like that all
right next law
it's ask lunch money time
okay justin asks love your show pomp and
pimp i'm pimp
for those who don't know
because of my initials not because i'm
an actor okay
oh okay gotta clarify the people these
days polina's initials are p-i-m-p which
you can't make that up okay been
watching palm for years and admire how
he always remains rational during these
crazy down times downturns respect
however this pomp ever expressed fud
fear uncertainty doubt also i had no
idea that's what fudd stood for no keep
going interesting
okay
when away from the mic oh so do you ever
express fud when away from the mic or is
my man truly fearless
will you answer first so this is really
interesting because i told him yesterday
evening i was like i'm surprised that
you're so calm
about this
given that you know it's a lot
uh with bitcoin but if bitcoin drops to
a thousand dollars the show's over but
not because the price went down to a
thousand because we're selling all the
equipment and we're literally going to
buy bitcoin
so
i just y'all better hope that it'll go
to a thousand because if it goes to a
thousand the show's over we ain't gonna
have equipment to live stream so um
wait what i'm just saying um no i'll be
here
you ain't selling you'll be talking in a
room by yourself because there ain't
gonna be no lights i'm gonna be no
cameras there's gonna be nothing here
me and me and
gutter groan was here okay
what else all right
um no i think so i think the only time
that i've seen you actually really
really upset was 28
19. what year was that no 2020 20 2020.
in all seriousness i'm usually pretty
chill in general so that helps uh and
then when it comes to financial assets
uh i just have like a very long time
horizon so like short-term price
movements almost never uh rattle me uh
2018 i was an animal i i was on offense
bitcoin dropped to uh 3 500 under 3 500
i was gobbling up whatever i could so
that was like very much offensive i had
a very specific view of the world and i
was willing to make a pretty big bet on
it uh in 2020 uh when the pandemic hit
that was not the case no one expected
that no one had a plan no one had
necessarily a view uh you know some
people thought like literally go outside
you're gonna die like it was it was not
good and bitcoin kept falling and
falling and falling the craziest part
about 2020 was i literally wrote uh i
think it was march 12th of 2020 was the
day that bitcoin fell 50 hey you know
big brain i'm pretty sure that was the
day uh and when it fell that morning i
wrote a piece and was like we are in a
liquidity crisis and i outlined what is
the liquidity crisis how does it work
assets sell off more than you think like
like i literally wrote out exactly what
was happening
and then bitcoin fell from eight
thousand to four thousand that day like
it would be like sitting down and be
like here's what's gonna happen today
and you write it and then as it's
happening you literally are like holy
[ __ ] my hair's on fire you're freaking
out et cetera and so i wasn't
necessarily like freaking out i was more
so just stunned and it's kind of like i
figure it's like a prize fight like you
get punched in the face
and you're just stunned and so when that
happened uh at one point i was just like
i'm literally just gonna watch this go
to zero like it was just falling so fast
and planet hit me with the
you should buy more and i was like what
and she was like yeah like you're
basically all in like just just no it's
like it's too late now i mean would you
guys sell after all this time
yeah after all all the all the pain all
the pain i was like yeah good point good
point good point
so
good team all right see ya
bye polina